This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. In Anthony Doar's wonderful novel, All the Light we cannot see, a radio host poses a question to an audience of children. The brain is locked in total darkness, he says. It floats in a clear liquid inside the skull, never in the light, and yet the world it constructs in the mind is full of light. It brims with color and movement. So how children does the brain which lives without a spark of light build for us a world full of light? It's not just about light of course, the world inside our heads is full of sound, movement and sensation.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在安东尼·多尔的精彩小说《所有我们看不见的光》中，一位电台主持人向一群孩子提出了一个问题。他说，大脑被锁在完全的黑暗中。它漂浮在颅骨内清澈的液体里，从未见过光，然而它在思维中构建的世界却充满了光。它充满了色彩和运动。那么，孩子们，大脑这个生活在没有一丝光亮中的器官，是如何为我们构建出一个充满光的世界的呢？当然，这不仅仅关乎光，我们头脑中的世界还充满了声音、运动和感觉。
It is suffused with feelings and emotion. Imagine for a moment that your brain was a person locked inside your head. How does this person create a world so rich, so varied and so beautiful when she is permanently trapped within the cage of your skull? Most of us have already answered. The brain has many messengers that bring it information. Signals stream in from our eyes and ears and skin. The brain takes in all these signals and like a film editor splicing together a movie, assembles our perceptions of
它充盈着情感和情绪。试想一下，如果你的大脑是一个被锁在你头颅里的人。当她被永久地困在你的颅骨牢笼中时，她是如何创造出一个如此丰富、多样且美丽的世界的呢？我们大多数人已经有了答案。大脑有许多传递信息的信使。信号从我们的眼睛、耳朵和皮肤源源不断地涌入。大脑接收所有这些信号，就像电影剪辑师拼接电影一样，组装起我们对
the world. When in recent years, some scientists have come to believe that this is not what actually happens. The light we see and the sounds we hear are not really comprised of signals from the outside world. Instead, they are mostly creations of the mind itself. When I first heard this idea, it made little sense to me. But then I came by some interesting experiments. For example, can you make out what I'm saying here? A novel?
世界的感知。然而近年来，一些科学家开始认为，事实并非如此。我们看到的光和听到的声音，并非真的由来自外部世界的信号组成。相反，它们大多是思维本身的创造。当我第一次听到这个观点时，我觉得它毫无道理。但后来我接触到了一些有趣的实验。例如，你能听出我在这里说的是什么吗？一本小说？
A novel we can't see? A plot surprise? A plot surprise? A plot surprise? A plot surprise? A plot surprise? A plot surprise? A plot surprise?
一本我们看不见的小说？一个情节反转？一个情节反转？一个情节反转？一个情节反转？一个情节反转？一个情节反转？一个情节反转？
A plot surprise? A plot surprise? A plot surprise? A plot surprise? A plot surprise? A plot surprise? right? Here's what I said. The novel, all the light we cannot see, won the Pulitzer Prize in 2015. Now, let me play you the same clip as before. If you can now make out the words, it's not because your mind decides for the audio. You tried doing that and it sounded like gibberish. You can do it now because your brain knew what was coming. It predicted what it was going to hear. As we will explore today, the brain is doing this in every domain.
一个情节反转？一个情节反转？一个情节反转？一个情节反转？一个情节反转？一个情节反转？对吧？我刚才说的是：小说《所有我们看不见的光》在2015年获得了普利策奖。现在，让我再为你播放一遍刚才那段音频。如果你现在能听懂这些词，那并不是因为你的大脑决定了音频的内容。你刚才试着去听，但听起来像胡言乱语。你现在能听懂是因为你的大脑预知了接下来会发生什么。它预测了它将要听到的内容。正如我们今天将要探讨的那样，大脑在每一个领域都在做这件事。
What you hear, yes, but also what you see, what you touch, what you smell. This week on Hidden Brain, the story of a scientist who has spent years studying how the brain constructs reality and the surprising implications of her ideas for our emotional lives. Lisa Fannman Barrett grew up in Toronto, Canada. It was the late 1960s. Her dad was out of the picture, so her mom raised her. Lisa would spend every weekend with her maternal grandparents. When she was five, her mom remarried. Lisa vividly remembered something that happened with her new stepfather on the day of the wedding. I remember his parents were there,
你听到的，是的，还有你看到的、你触摸到的、你闻到的。本周的《隐藏的大脑》，讲述了一位科学家多年来研究大脑如何构建现实的故事，以及她的观点对我们情感生活产生的惊人影响。丽莎·费尔德曼·巴雷特在加拿大安大略省多伦多市长大。那是20世纪60年代末。她的父亲不在身边，所以是她母亲抚养她长大。丽莎每个周末都会和外祖父母在一起。她五岁时，母亲再婚了。丽莎清晰地记得婚礼当天与新继父发生的一件事。我记得他的父母也在场，
and I remember his parents saying to me, so I think I had met them maybe once or twice. I didn't really know them at all, and I remember my step-grandmother saying to me, well, go over to your grandparents and congratulate them on this wedding. Now, she's saying this to a five-year-old. What does a five-year-old know?
我记得他的父母对我说话，我想我可能只见过他们一两次。我根本不认识他们，我记得我的继祖母对我说：“去向你的祖父母祝贺这场婚礼。”你看，她是对一个五岁的孩子说这话。一个五岁的孩子懂什么？
And I remember saying to her, why do I have to do that? I don't have to go congratulate my Z80 or that's what I used to call them. It's the Yiddish word for grandfather. You know, just sort of like, what? Don't tell me what to do. Lisa's step-grandmother got upset.
我记得我对她说：“我为什么要那样做？我不必去祝贺我的Zayde（或者我过去常那样称呼他们）。”这是意第绪语中“祖父”的意思。你知道，就像是说：“什么？别告诉我该做什么。”丽莎的继祖母很生气。
She smacked Lisa across the face. In time, Lisa would receive other messages that she was responsible for how people felt. Another incident took place a couple of years after the wedding. It was a Saturday morning. I was probably seven years old. I was watching cartoons, which is something I used to do in Saturday mornings with my sister. I had probably just finished some kind of sugary cereal. But I never
她打了丽莎一巴掌。随着时间的推移，丽莎还会收到其他信息，告诉她必须为别人的感受负责。另一件事发生在婚礼几年后。那是一个周六的早晨。我大概七岁。我正在看动画片，这是我过去常和姐姐在周六早上做的事情。我可能刚吃完某种含糖麦片。但我从来
really liked the sugary milk that was left over. So I put the bowl in the sink. And then I went off to my room to do whatever I was going to do. And my mother became very irritated that I had left a bowl in the sink instead of rinsing it out, that I had left it for her. And my stepfather became pretty enraged that I had upset my mother. This was a theme that was, you know, constant in my home that I was responsible for my mother's emotions. And I had upset her and he basically grounded me for a month.
不喜欢剩下的含糖牛奶。所以我把碗放进水槽里。然后我就回房间去做我自己的事了。我母亲因为我把碗留在水槽里而不是冲洗干净，因为我把碗留给她洗而感到非常恼火。而我的继父因为我惹母亲生气而变得非常愤怒。这在我家里是一个持续存在的主题，那就是我必须为我母亲的情绪负责。我惹她生气了，他基本上禁足了我一个月。
My grandfather was gonna take me to the circus that afternoon, so I was grounded. So I couldn't go to the circus, which I'd been looking forward to for a really long time. And then he hit me with a belt, with the buckle of a belt. Oh my God. Which left welts.
那天下午我祖父本要带我去马戏团，但我被禁足了。所以我没能去成我期待已久的马戏团。然后他用皮带抽我，用皮带扣。天哪。这留下了伤痕。
That was something that he didn't do all the time, but he sometimes did. And it left welts, you know, and marks on my skin that took a long time to heal. And this is for leaving a bowl of milk in the sink? Because my mother became irritated. Or you must have burst into tears right then and there. Absolutely. But you know what? You also learn to control your tears because your tears can make someone feel guilty for
那不是他经常做的事，但他有时会这样做。它留下了伤痕，你知道，我皮肤上的印记过了很久才愈合。这仅仅是因为把一碗牛奶留在水槽里？因为我母亲感到恼火。或者你当时一定立刻就哭了出来。当然。但你知道吗？你也会学会控制眼泪，因为你的眼泪会让别人为
their own bad behavior, in which case if you're being held responsible for their feelings, then you pay the price. You've said a couple of times that your stepfather held you accountable for your mother's feelings and you also just said that your stepfather might hold you accountable for his feelings. Talk about that idea for a moment. How did he pick up on the sense that you were responsible for how they felt? Well, he would say it.
他们自己的不良行为感到内疚，在这种情况下，如果你被要求为他们的感受负责，那么你就要付出代价。你提到过几次你的继父让你为母亲的感受负责，你也刚说过你的继父可能会让你为他的感受负责。谈谈这个想法。他是如何察觉到你对他们的感受负有责任的？嗯，他会说出来的。
He would say, you made your mother feel embarrassed. You made your mother, you embarrassed your mother. You made your mother angry. You made your mother sad. For example, when I was 12, I lived in a Jewish area. My family is Jewish. Everyone was having bar mitzvahs and bar mitzvahs. I personally wasn't because I didn't go to
他会说：“你让你母亲感到尴尬了。你让你母亲，你让你母亲丢脸了。你让你母亲生气了。你让你母亲伤心了。”例如，我12岁时，住在犹太人区。我的家庭是犹太人。每个人都在举行受戒礼（Bar Mitzvah和Bat Mitzvah）。我个人没有，因为我没去
Hebrew school. We couldn't afford that. But everyone was going to bar mitzvahs and bar mitzvahs. And it's not crazy like it is now where people are spending, like $100,000 or whatever on these massive parties. But there was still a party that you had to go to and a present that you had to give and you had to wear a dress and you needed shoes
希伯来语学校。我们负担不起。但每个人都在参加受戒礼。那不像现在这样疯狂，人们在这些大型派对上花费10万美元或更多。但仍然有必须参加的派对，必须送的礼物，你必须穿裙子，你需要鞋子，
and I didn't have dresses and I didn't have shoes. I had one pair of shoes and they weren't party shoes. And I remember I wrote a little note to my mother on a piece of paper and I decorated it with, you know, I like to draw. So I decorated it with like all sorts of flowers and balloons and like party things. And I said, can I have a pair of party shoes? I slipped it under the door
而我没有裙子，也没有鞋子。我只有一双鞋，而且不是派对穿的鞋。我记得我在一张纸上给母亲写了一张小纸条，我用——你知道，我喜欢画画——所以我用各种花、气球和派对元素装饰了它。我说：“我能有一双派对穿的鞋吗？”我把它从门缝里塞了进去，
when she was in the bathroom. I honestly don't think that my mother would say to my stepfather, she made me feel this way. I think she would say, probably, I'm guessing, but knowing my mother the way that I do, I would expect that she would say, I feel bad that we don't have the money to buy her a pair of shoes. And so they'll, let's just say that I didn't go to Bar Mitzvah's or Bob Mitzvah's was for like a month, which made me very unpopular because I had already RSVP that I was going to these parties and then at the last minute sort of had to cancel because I was grounded.
当时她在浴室里。我真的不认为我母亲会对我继父说：“她让我有这种感觉。”我想她可能会说——我是在猜测，但以我对母亲的了解，我预计她会说：“我感到很难过，因为我们没有钱给她买一双鞋。”所以他们——我们就说我有一个月没去参加受戒礼，这让我非常不受欢迎，因为我已经回复说我会参加这些派对，然后在最后一刻不得不取消，因为我被禁足了。
Wait, you see your stepfather grounded you because you sent this note to your mother? Yeah, like I slipped it under the door asking, can I please have a pair of party shoes? Yeah, the response was, you know, probably came like a day later. And it was swift and intense. As you can tell, Lisa had a strained relationship with her stepfather. She was also something of an outlier in her family. She was the first to go to college and then to graduate school. But our story today is not about parent-child relationships
等等，你是说你的继父因为你给母亲写了这张纸条而禁足你？是的，就像我把它从门缝里塞进去问：“请问我能有一双派对鞋吗？”是的，回应大概是在一天后到来的。而且非常迅速且强烈。如你所见，丽莎与继父的关系很紧张。她在家里也算是个异类。她是家里第一个上大学，然后读研究生的人。但我们今天的故事不是关于亲子关系，
or even about the particulars of Lisa's own childhood. The reason these stories are relevant to our episode today is because they illustrate an idea that is ubiquitous in all of our lives. You probably had times in your own life when someone told you that you made them feel sad or angry or happy, that you were the cause of their emotions, that you were responsible for how they feel. You have surely felt this way about others, someone cuts you off in traffic and you say that the other driver made you upset. A friend brings over some food when you are sick and you say your friend has comforted you.
甚至不是关于丽莎童年的细节。这些故事与我们今天的节目相关，是因为它们阐释了一个在我们生活中无处不在的观点。你可能在自己的生活中也遇到过有人告诉你，你让他们感到悲伤、愤怒或快乐，你是他们情绪的起因，你对他们的感受负有责任。你肯定也对别人有过这种感觉，有人在交通中强行超车，你会说那个司机让你心烦意乱。朋友在你生病时送来食物，你会说你的朋友安慰了你。
We say that a winning sports team has churras up and that a losing sports team has brought us down. It certainly feels as though our minds are taking in signals from the outside world and assembling our internal world, that our emotions are caused by the things that happen to us. But as Lisa went on to become a psychologist and neuroscientist, she was to discover that our feelings are not in fact responses to the world. They are really predictions about the world.
我们说获胜的运动队让我们振奋，失败的运动队让我们沮丧。这确实感觉像是我们的大脑在接收来自外部世界的信号并组装我们的内心世界，我们的情绪是由发生在我们身上的事情引起的。但随着丽莎成为心理学家和神经科学家，她发现我们的感受实际上并不是对世界的反应。它们实际上是对世界的预测。
She began to ask herself a question, what happens if we change those predictions? You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. When high school students start to learn to conduct experiments, that teachers usually tell them to start by repeating, or replicating, famous experiments from the past. The physicist Isaac Newton, for example, discovered a long time ago that heavier objects do not fall faster than lighter objects. All objects on Earth experience gravity and this gravitational forces constant, regardless of whether the object is heavy or light. When I was in high school,
她开始问自己一个问题：如果我们改变这些预测会怎样？你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。当高中生开始学习进行实验时，老师通常会告诉他们从重复或复制过去著名的实验开始。例如，物理学家艾萨克·牛顿很久以前就发现，较重的物体下落速度并不比较轻的物体快。地球上的所有物体都受到重力的影响，这种重力是恒定的，无论物体是重还是轻。当我上高中的时候，
I remember teachers showing us how to replicate Newton's experiment using two balls of different weight that roll down an incline. When Lisa Feldman-Barratt started working on her PhD, she decided to replicate some famous experiments. She was planning to become a clinician and help people suffering with anxiety and depression, but she also enjoyed doing research. The theory that I was working with was something called self-discrepancy theory. There were a set of very simple experiments that had been published where people were just asked to list the attributes or properties of who they thought they were. I'm a nice person, I'm an honest person, I'm a complex person, I'm a whatever.
我记得老师向我们展示如何使用两个不同重量的球沿斜坡滚下来来复制牛顿的实验。当丽莎·费尔德曼·巴雷特开始攻读博士学位时，她决定复制一些著名的实验。她计划成为一名临床医生，帮助患有焦虑和抑郁症的人，但她也喜欢做研究。我当时研究的理论被称为“自我差异理论”。有一组已经发表的非常简单的实验，人们被要求列出他们认为自己是谁的属性或特质。我是个好人，我是个诚实的人，我是个复杂的人，我是个什么什么样的人。
And then the features of who they're ideal self. And then you can compute the similarity or dissimilarity, and then you can also ask people how they feel. The idea was that if there were mismatches between how people described themselves and who they wanted to be, this would make people sad. As part of the experiment, Lisa had to ask people how they felt and carefully distinguish emotions like sadness from emotions like anxiety. That's what I did in the first couple of studies, where I was asking people in different ways
然后是他们理想自我的特征。然后你可以计算相似度或不相似度，你还可以询问人们的感受。这个想法是，如果人们对自己的描述与他们想要成为的人之间存在不匹配，这会让人感到悲伤。作为实验的一部分，丽莎必须询问人们的感受，并仔细区分悲伤和焦虑等情绪。这就是我在最初几项研究中所做的，我以不同的方式询问人们，
or I was attempting to measure emotion in different ways. But I was never able to replicate those experiments. Lisa's volunteers seem to have a hard time accurately classifying how they felt. As a graduate student, Lisa figured she had not run the experiment properly. She tried again, and again, and again.
或者我试图以不同的方式测量情绪。但我从来没能复制那些实验。丽莎的志愿者似乎很难准确地分类他们的感受。作为一名研究生，丽莎认为自己没有正确地进行实验。她又试了一次，又一次，又一次。
Well, I thought, well, I must be doing something wrong. Maybe I'm not sampling properly, or maybe I'm sampling people at the wrong time of the semester. After she failed for the eighth time, Lisa said, OK, I am clearly missing something here. What am I not getting? I went back and I looked at the eight experiments that had failed and I realized, oh, actually, the reason why they're failing was that when people are reporting how they feel, how much sadness do you feel,
嗯，我想，我一定是在做错什么。也许我的抽样不正确，或者我是在学期中错误的时间抽样。在第八次失败后，丽莎说：“好吧，我显然漏掉了什么。我没弄明白什么？”我回去看了那八个失败的实验，我意识到，哦，实际上，它们失败的原因是，当人们报告他们的感受时——你感到多悲伤，
how hopeless do you feel, how depressed do you feel, you're basically giving them a set of words and you're asking them to describe their feelings. And you can do the same thing with anxiety, how anxious do you feel, how jittery do you feel, how fearful do you feel, and so on and so forth. And what I noticed was that when people were reporting that they were feeling intense sadness, they were also reporting that they were feeling intense anxiety. When people reported that they were feeling calm, they were also reporting that they were feeling calm, they were also reporting that they were feeling happy. So what was happening here in these eight studies is that people were reporting that they felt
你感到多绝望，你感到多抑郁——你基本上是给他们一组词，让他们描述自己的感受。你可以对焦虑做同样的事情：你感到多焦虑，你感到多紧张，你感到多恐惧，等等。我注意到的是，当人们报告说他们感到强烈的悲伤时，他们也报告说他们感到强烈的焦虑。当人们报告说他们感到平静时，他们也报告说他们感到快乐。所以在这八项研究中发生的事情是，人们报告说他们感到
both sad and anxious or that they felt neither of those emotions, that they felt calm and happy. Basically, people were using sadness and anxiety as synonyms for I feel like crap. And this was happening across eight different studies. And so I thought, well, that's the problem. The problem is that people are not reporting accurately how they're feeling. This was why the results of the studies were modeled. If people reported feeling sad, when they really should have said they were feeling anxious
既悲伤又焦虑，或者他们没有感受到这两种情绪中的任何一种，他们感到平静和快乐。基本上，人们把悲伤和焦虑当作“我感觉很糟糕”的同义词。这种情况发生在八项不同的研究中。所以我心想，好吧，这就是问题所在。问题在于人们没有准确地报告他们的感受。这就是为什么研究结果如此混乱。如果人们报告感到悲伤，而他们本应该说他们感到焦虑，
or vice versa, the researchers wouldn't be able to tell how mismatches between people's ideal selves and actual selves produce sadness. If I want to measure emotion, I've got to find a way to measure how they actually feel. Then I'll be able to properly test the hypothesis of the self-descriptancy hypotheses. Maybe I might also figure out why is it that people are having trouble separating anxiety and sadness. Because everyone knows that anxiety and depression, sadness and fear, that these are different emotion categories. And I became just captivated and intrigued
或者反之亦然，研究人员就无法判断人们的理想自我与现实自我之间的不匹配是如何产生悲伤的。如果我想测量情绪，我必须找到一种方法来测量他们真实的感受。然后我就能正确地检验自我差异假设。也许我还能弄清楚为什么人们在区分焦虑和悲伤方面有困难。因为每个人都知道焦虑和抑郁、悲伤和恐惧是不同的情绪类别。我变得非常着迷，并对
by this new problem that I had encountered. In her 30-year-old graduate school, Lisa experienced something in her personal life that matched the experience of her volunteers. There was someone at the university who kept asking me out for coffee or for dinner. I just didn't find this person very appealing, I guess. And I just wasn't really that interested. And I just ignored his advances, so to speak, his interest. But he was persistent, you know. And so finally I thought, all right, well, I'm just going to go out with him for coffee.
我遇到的这个新问题产生了兴趣。在30岁读研究生时，丽莎在个人生活中经历了一件事，这与她志愿者的经历相吻合。大学里有个人一直约我喝咖啡或吃晚饭。我猜我只是觉得这个人不太吸引人。我真的没那么感兴趣。所以我可以说忽略了他的追求，他的兴趣。但他很坚持，你知道。所以最后我想，好吧，我就和他出去喝杯咖啡吧。
We'll just have coffee and then, you know, I'll tell him, I don't wanna start a relationship. So we went out for coffee and we went to, you know, this place very close by the university that all the graduate students used to go to. And we're sitting there having coffee in this wonderful little Mediterranean restaurant. And I start to notice that like my cheeks are flush.
我们喝杯咖啡，然后，你知道，我会告诉他，我不想开始一段关系。所以我们出去喝咖啡，去了离大学很近的一家所有研究生都常去的地方。我们坐在那儿，在那家美妙的小地中海餐厅里喝咖啡。我开始注意到我的脸颊发烫。
Like I'm flushing and I'm a little warm. And my heart was pounding a little harder than usual. And I was having a little trouble concentrating. And I thought, am I like attracted to this guy? Have I been wrong all this time? Maybe he is more interesting than I thought. Maybe I'm like, I guess he's not that bad looking and I guess he's sort of more interesting than I thought before. Gee, maybe I was wrong. And, you know, so by the end of the conversation, we're there
就像我在脸红，我有点热。我的心跳比平时快了一点。我有点难以集中注意力。我想，我是被这个家伙吸引了吗？我一直都错了吗？也许他比我想象的更有趣。也许我——我想他长得也不算太差，而且我想他比我之前想的要有趣一些。天哪，也许我错了。你知道，谈话结束时，我们在那儿
for like two hours. And, you know, he asked like, can we see each other again? Can we have dinner? And I'm like, yeah, sure, let's have dinner, you know, for sure. Let's, let's then I start to walk back to the place where I'm living and I'm thinking to myself, okay, so maybe there's something here. And, you know, you shouldn't believe your first impressions. I fumble for my keys, as I always do. I unlock the door and then a wave of intense nausea just flares up.
待了大约两个小时。你知道，他问：“我们能再见面吗？能一起吃晚饭吗？”我说：“是的，当然，我们去吃晚饭吧，当然。”然后我开始走回我住的地方，我心想，好吧，也许这里面有什么。而且，你知道，你不应该相信你的第一印象。我像往常一样摸索着钥匙。我打开门，然后一阵强烈的恶心感涌了上来。
I drop my stuff on the floor, slam the door, run to the bathroom, and let's just say, spend some time, you know, what do they say, praying to the poor sling God and then was in bed for a week with the flu. What Lisa had thought was romantic attraction was not in fact romantic attraction. She had just been falling sick. How could anyone mix up these two very different things? If anything, this was an extreme form of what Lisa's volunteers had been doing in her eight failed experiments. They had been mixing up anxiety and depression, or calmness and happiness.
我把东西扔在地板上，砰地关上门，跑进浴室，我们就说，花了一些时间，你知道，他们怎么说来着，向马桶神祈祷，然后因为流感在床上躺了一个星期。丽莎原以为是浪漫的吸引力，实际上根本不是。她只是生病了。怎么会有人把这两件截然不同的事情搞混呢？如果说有什么不同的话，这只是丽莎的志愿者在她那八个失败的实验中所做事情的极端形式。他们把焦虑和抑郁，或者平静和快乐搞混了。
She was mixing up the signals of a viral infection and romantic attraction. But Lisa failed to draw the right implications from what had happened. She was still certain that people felt happy or sad or anxious or angry. They just had a hard time articulating what they felt. Her job as a scientist was to find an objective way to identify emotions. It took Lisa a long time and well after she had graduated to realize her data had been telling her a different story for a very long time. It took me probably systematically about 10 years, maybe more, to come to the conclusion that there are no indicators, objective indicators for an emotion.
她把病毒感染的信号和浪漫的吸引力搞混了。但丽莎没能从发生的事情中得出正确的结论。她仍然确信人们会感到快乐、悲伤、焦虑或愤怒。他们只是很难表达出他们的感受。她作为科学家的工作是找到一种客观的方法来识别情绪。丽莎花了很长时间，在毕业很久之后才意识到，她的数据在很长一段时间里一直在告诉她一个不同的故事。我大概花了10年时间，也许更久，才系统地得出结论：情绪没有客观指标。
An emotion word, like anger, isn't a thing. Anger isn't a thing. It's actually a category of highly variable instances. Sometimes when you're angry, you shout. Sometimes when you're angry, you laugh. Sometimes when you're angry, you cry. Sometimes when you're angry, you sit silently and plot the demise of your enemy. Sometimes you scowl about half the time when people scowl, they're not angry. That's significant compared to chance, but it also means that 50% of the time, if you assume that when someone is scowling, they're angry, you're going to be wrong.
一个情绪词，比如“愤怒”，并不是一个东西。愤怒不是一个东西。它实际上是一个高度可变的实例类别。有时当你生气时，你会大喊大叫。有时当你生气时，你会大笑。有时当你生气时，你会哭泣。有时当你生气时，你会静静地坐着，策划敌人的灭亡。有时你会皱眉，大约有一半的时间，当人们皱眉时，他们并不生气。这与随机情况相比是显著的，但也意味着50%的情况下，如果你假设某人皱眉就是生气，那你就会错。
Anger or sadness or fear, whatever, when we refer to unemotion, we're really referring to an instance of a category. That's the first thing to understand. So when you look at someone in their scowling, it could be that the person is angry. It could be that somebody just told them a really bad joke. It could be that they're concentrating really hard. It could be that they're experiencing a bad bout of gas.
愤怒、悲伤或恐惧，无论什么，当我们提到一种情绪时，我们实际上指的是一个类别的一个实例。这是首先要理解的。所以当你看着某人皱眉时，可能是因为那个人很生气。也可能是因为有人刚给他们讲了一个很烂的笑话。也可能是因为他们正在非常努力地集中注意力。也可能是因为他们正在经历严重的胀气。
Any of those things and also other states could have produced that scowl on their face. And you have to make a guess based on your past experiences about what that scowl means in this context. Lisa ran an experiment that showed our ability to read emotions is heavily dependent on the context. Just like that garbled sentence at the top of the episode that made sense once you knew what I was saying, it is the context that helps us predict the emotions of others.
任何这些事情以及其他状态都可能导致他们脸上的皱眉。你必须根据你过去的经验来猜测这种皱眉在这个语境下意味着什么。丽莎做了一个实验，表明我们解读情绪的能力在很大程度上取决于语境。就像本集开头那句乱码句子一样，一旦你知道我在说什么，它就变得有意义了，正是语境帮助我们预测他人的情绪。
In the study, Lisa and her colleagues had an actor portray the emotion in various scenarios. One scenario asked people to imagine that a coworker had caught them stealing and was going to tell the boss. The actor tried to depict the facial expression of someone trapped in that difficult situation. Lisa then brought in volunteers and showed them the photos of the actor. She asked the volunteers to guess what emotion the actor was portraying. For another group of volunteers, she provided the scenario the actor was portraying. For another group of volunteers, she provided the scenario the actor was trying to portray and asked the volunteers to guess the
在这项研究中，丽莎和她的同事让一名演员在各种场景中表现出某种情绪。一个场景要求人们想象一个同事抓住了他们偷窃，并打算告诉老板。演员试图描绘出陷入那种困境的人的面部表情。丽莎随后带入志愿者，向他们展示了演员的照片。她要求志愿者猜测演员在表现什么情绪。对于另一组志愿者，她提供了演员试图表现的场景，并要求志愿者猜测
emotions of people caught up in that scenario. A third group of volunteers got both the scenario and the photos of the actor. We compare people who rated the face alone to the people who rated the face in the context, right, to people who rate the context alone. So we can ask the question, what is driving people's perceptions? Is it the expression on the face? Is it the context or is it some combination? And the answer is, it's mostly the context. The context always trumps the actual facial movements.
陷入该场景的人的情绪。第三组志愿者同时得到了场景和演员的照片。我们比较了那些只评价面部表情的人和那些在语境中评价面部表情的人，对吧，以及那些只评价语境的人。所以我们可以问一个问题：是什么在驱动人们的感知？是脸上的表情？是语境，还是某种组合？答案是，主要是语境。语境总是胜过实际的面部动作。
When you're asking the question about how is a perceiver experiencing a person's face? There's no inherent meaning in the face. The signals in the face are not inherently meaningful as a motion. The context is creating the meaning basically for what those facial movements mean. Lisa had an epiphany. If the context is what helps us read the emotions of others, is it possible that it is the context that also shapes how we read our own emotions? She thought back to the story of her bad date. When she thought about it again, she realized that the interpretation of her emotion completely depended on the context.
当你问感知者如何体验一个人的脸时，脸上并没有固有的意义。脸上的信号作为情绪本身并不具有固有的意义。语境基本上为这些面部动作的含义创造了意义。丽莎顿悟了。如果语境是帮助我们解读他人情绪的东西，那么语境是否也可能塑造我们解读自己情绪的方式呢？她回想起那次糟糕的约会。当她再次思考时，她意识到她对情绪的解读完全取决于语境。
The more accurate way that I would describe what happened is that my brain made sense of those physical signals coming from the body as attraction. You know your brain is trapped inside a dark silent box called your skull and it's receiving signals from your body. You have sensory surfaces all over your body in in your retina, in each eye, the cochlea in each ear, your skin. You have sensory surfaces inside your body, for glucose, for temperature. Your brain is constantly receiving sensory signals from the sensory surfaces of your body. That informed the brain of the changes in the body and in the world,
我描述所发生事情的更准确方式是，我的大脑将来自身体的那些物理信号解读为吸引力。你知道你的大脑被困在一个叫做颅骨的黑暗、安静的盒子里，它正在接收来自你身体的信号。你的身体各处都有感觉表面，在视网膜里，在每只眼睛里，在每只耳朵的耳蜗里，在你的皮肤上。你的身体内部也有感觉表面，用于感知葡萄糖、温度。你的大脑不断地从你身体的感觉表面接收感觉信号。这通知大脑身体和世界发生的变化，
but the brain doesn't know the causes. It only knows the signals themselves, which are the outcomes. And this is what philosophers call an inverse problem. So your brain is constantly having to solve an inverse problem. It has to guess at the meaning of the causes of those signals. And even when your brain guesses wrong, those guesses become your experience basically. So what my brain did during that coffee
但大脑并不知道原因。它只知道信号本身，也就是结果。这就是哲学家所说的“反问题”。所以你的大脑必须不断地解决一个反问题。它必须猜测这些信号产生的原因的含义。即使你的大脑猜错了，这些猜测也基本上变成了你的体验。所以我的大脑在那次喝咖啡期间所做的，
was take these sensory signals, which were being caused by a pathogen, biologically speaking in my body, but my brain didn't know, a pathogen, biologically speaking in my body, but my brain didn't know about that pathogen. It just knew the outcomes of the pathogen, which were the signals. So I think authentically, I felt romantic attraction in that moment.
就是接收这些感觉信号，从生物学上讲，这些信号是由我体内的病原体引起的，但我的大脑并不知道那个病原体。它只知道病原体的结果，也就是那些信号。所以我认为，在那一刻，我真实地感受到了浪漫的吸引力。
It's just that the biological cause was different than what it might have been at other times. That's how I would understand what happened now. Hmm. When you went on that date with your fellow graduate student, you'd have previously experiences of what it's like to have coffee with someone you were attracted to. You sort of knew what your face being flushed could mean, and you knew what a flutter in your heart could mean.
只是生物学上的原因与它在其他时候可能的原因不同。这就是我现在理解所发生事情的方式。嗯。当你和那位研究生同学去约会时，你之前有过和吸引你的人喝咖啡的经历。你多少知道脸红可能意味着什么，你也知道心跳加速可能意味着什么。
And in some ways, as you're sitting there having coffee with this other person, your brain in some ways is saying, where have these things happened to me before? What is the context that makes sense here? And your brain is trying to make sense of what these signals coming in are actually telling you. Yes, exactly. That's exactly right. And each guess, each prediction isn't weighed equally, right?
在某种程度上，当你坐在那里和另一个人喝咖啡时，你的大脑在某种程度上是在说：“这些事情以前在哪里发生过？”什么语境在这里是有意义的？你的大脑正试图弄清楚这些传入的信号实际上在告诉你什么。是的，完全正确。就是这样。而且每一个猜测，每一个预测，权重并不相等，对吧？
There's a prior probability. There's some increased chance that one predictive context, one story, is going to be more likely than another. Right. And so your brain is weighing those. Yeah. And if you hadn't gone on the date that day, if your face had just felt flushed, and your heart felt like it was fluttering and you felt a little uncomfortable and you would just happen
有一个先验概率。某种预测语境、某个故事比另一个更有可能发生的几率增加了。对。所以你的大脑正在权衡这些。是的。如果你那天没有去约会，如果你的脸只是感到发烫，你的心跳感觉像是在加速，你感到有点不舒服，而你只是碰巧
to be in your lab, you wouldn't have drawn the conclusion, oh, I'm attracted to someone, you might well have drawn the conclusion, something's wrong, I think I might be feeling ill. Exactly, exactly. That's exactly right. If I had been out for a run and I was feeling flushed, I would experience it as fatigue and that I need to have a glass of water or a chocolate muffin, I don't know. But there were other stories that my brain could have told. And I'll just say that to me what the evidence suggests is the following, that emotions aren't built into your brain, they're built by your brain in the moment as needed, and the specificity or granularity with which an emotion is built depends on what past experiences
在实验室里，你可能不会得出“哦，我被某人吸引了”的结论，你很可能会得出“有什么不对劲，我想我可能生病了”的结论。完全正确，完全正确。就是这样。如果我当时在跑步，感到脸红，我会把它体验为疲劳，我需要喝杯水或吃个巧克力松饼，我不知道。但我的大脑本可以讲述其他故事。我只想说，对我而言，证据表明了以下一点：情绪不是内置在大脑中的，它们是根据需要由大脑在当下构建的，而构建情绪的特异性或粒度取决于你的大脑正在调动什么过去的经验
your brain is bringing to bear to predict and make sense of the incoming sensory signals from the body and from the world. Our feelings turn out to be predictions about the world, not reactions to it. The our ways our brains prepare us for action. When you hear footsteps coming up quickly behind you in a dark alley, your brain is making a prediction that you might need to run away and you feel fear.
来预测和理解来自身体和世界的传入感觉信号。事实证明，我们的感受是对世界的预测，而不是对世界的反应。这是我们大脑为行动做准备的方式。当你听到黑暗小巷里身后传来急促的脚步声时，你的大脑正在做出一个预测，即你可能需要逃跑，于是你感到了恐惧。
When your child cartels up next to you on the couch, your brain predicts it will experience warmth and love and you reach out to give your child a hug. Most of the time of course, our emotions don't feel like predictions, but there are times when we can actually see the predictive machinery in action. So let's say you hear a loud bang. What could that loud bang be? It could be a firecracker, it could be a car backfiring, it could be a gunshot, it could be any number of different things.
当你的孩子在沙发上蜷缩在你身边时，你的大脑预测它将体验到温暖和爱，于是你伸出手去拥抱你的孩子。当然，大多数时候，我们的情绪感觉不像预测，但有时我们确实可以看到预测机制在起作用。所以，假设你听到一声巨响。那声巨响可能是什么？可能是鞭炮，可能是汽车回火，可能是枪声，可能是任何数量不同的东西。
Exactly. And what do you do when it's a firecracker versus a car backfiring versus a gunshot? You do very different things. So when a brain asks a question, it's a question of what do I need to do next to keep myself alive? That's the question that the brain is always asking, what do I have to do?
没错。当你面对鞭炮、汽车回火和枪声时，你会怎么做？你会做非常不同的事情。所以当大脑提出一个问题时，这是一个关于“为了保持生存，我接下来需要做什么”的问题。这就是大脑一直在问的问题：我必须做什么？
But the interesting thing here is that for the most part, brains are not reacting to the world. The brain doesn't hear a sound and then say, what is that? What the brain is doing is predicting. It's predicting all the time. What actions will be required in the next instance? And what sensory signals will be arriving in the next instant.
但这里有趣的是，在很大程度上，大脑并不是在对世界做出反应。大脑不会听到声音然后说：“那是什么？”大脑所做的是预测。它一直在预测。接下来的一瞬间需要什么行动？以及接下来的一瞬间会有什么感觉信号到达。
And then it compares those predictions to the incoming sense data. So the sensory signals from the body, you know, from your eyes and your ears and your skin and your nose and all the surfaces inside your body are not stimuli. They're signals that either confirm predictions or they change them. You know, I was in Orlando, Florida some time ago, and I was sitting in my hotel room in the evening, and I heard some booms, you know, loud noises. And for a minute, I was like, what are those noises? What could they be? And then I remember, of course, that I was at a resort in Disney World.
然后它将这些预测与传入的感觉数据进行比较。所以来自身体的感觉信号，你知道，来自你的眼睛、耳朵、皮肤、鼻子以及你身体内部所有表面的信号，不是刺激。它们是确认预测或改变预测的信号。你知道，前段时间我在佛罗里达州的奥兰多，晚上我坐在酒店房间里，听到了一些轰鸣声，你知道，巨大的噪音。有一分钟，我在想：“那些噪音是什么？它们可能是什么？”然后我记得，当然，我是在迪士尼世界的一个度假村。
I was there giving a talk. And I said, it's Disney World, so it's evening. And every day, at the end of the day, Disney World celebrates the end of the day with the fireworks display. So I rushed to the window, threw up with the blinds, and got to watch the fireworks for a little while. But this process where you hear the booms, you're trying to figure out what it is, you're trying to make sense. I'm taking
我在那里做演讲。我说：“这是迪士尼世界，所以现在是晚上。”每天，在一天结束时，迪士尼世界都会用烟花表演来庆祝一天的结束。所以我冲到窗前，拉开百叶窗，看了一会儿烟花。但这个过程，你听到轰鸣声，你试图弄清楚它是什么，你试图理解。我正在
into account the fact that I'm in Orlando, I'm a Disney world, that changes the meaning of the booms that I'm hearing. And my brain essentially has made a prediction of saying, these booms are probably not someone opening fire on you. These booms are fireworks and you should rush to the window to get a glimpse of them. Exactly. And in fact, if you read reports of people who have actually been in situations where there is gunfire, at first, they don't know what's happening. They can't tell necessarily that what they're hearing is a gun. And then when they realize it's a gun, they can't tell necessarily if it's friend or
考虑到我身处奥兰多，我在迪士尼世界，这改变了我听到的轰鸣声的含义。我的大脑本质上做出了一个预测，说：“这些轰鸣声可能不是有人在向你开火。这些轰鸣声是烟花，你应该冲到窗前看一眼。”没错。事实上，如果你阅读那些真正处于有枪击情况的人的报告，起初，他们不知道发生了什么。他们不一定能分辨出他们听到的是枪声。然后当他们意识到是枪声时，他们不一定能分辨出是敌是
foe. It's not a situation that we're infrequently because most of the time we're not sitting around wondering what is that flash of light, what is that chemical change, what is that, you know, most of the time, our brains are predicting pretty well, but there are these moments where, you know, a brain makes itself aware of having to guess. Most of the time, our predictions don't feel like predictions. When I reach for the mug on the desk in front of me, it feels as though I am looking at the mug
友。这不是我们不常遇到的情况，因为大多数时候我们不会坐着想“那道闪光是什么，那个化学变化是什么，那个是什么”，你知道，大多数时候，我们的大脑预测得相当好，但确实有这些时刻，你知道，大脑让自己意识到必须去猜测。大多数时候，我们的预测感觉不像预测。当我伸手去拿面前桌子上的杯子时，感觉就像是我在看着杯子
and directing my fingers to grasp the handle. But what is really happening is that I have reached for my mug so many hundreds of times that my brain can precisely predict the size, weight and location of the mug. It can predict how I will raise the mug to my lips and what my tea is going to taste like. It still uses visual signals from my eyes, tactile signals from my fingers, and the taste signals from my tongue, but only to fine tune its predictions. If I have forgotten to add sugar to my tea, my taste buds will inform my brain that its prediction of the taste of the tea was off.
并指挥我的手指去抓握把。但真正发生的是，我已经伸手去拿杯子几百次了，以至于我的大脑可以精确地预测杯子的大小、重量和位置。它可以预测我将如何把杯子举到嘴边，以及我的茶会是什么味道。它仍然使用来自眼睛的视觉信号、来自手指的触觉信号和来自舌头的味觉信号，但只是为了微调它的预测。如果我忘了在茶里加糖，我的味蕾会通知大脑，它对茶味道的预测是不准确的。
It will make me add some sugar. Why do all this is predicting, instead of simply painting a picture of the world from the signals coming into the brain? Since most of what most of us do most of the time involves things we have done before, Lisa says it will be metabolically inefficient to process everything as if it were happening for the first time. The most effective way to run a system
它会让我加点糖。为什么要进行所有这些预测，而不是简单地根据进入大脑的信号描绘出一幅世界图景呢？由于我们大多数人大多数时候所做的大部分事情都涉及我们以前做过的事情，丽莎说，如果把一切都当作第一次发生那样去处理，在代谢上是低效的。运行一个系统最有效的方法
is to predict the state of the system and correct when necessary. It's not to wait and react to things. Reaction is more expensive metabolically than prediction. And a major selection pressure on a species but also on an individual, like an individual's ability, for example, to remain healthy and to be able to reproduce, pass its genes onto the next generation, is metabolic fitness, metabolic efficiency.
是预测系统的状态并在必要时进行修正。而不是等待并对事物做出反应。反应在代谢上比预测更昂贵。物种以及个体（例如个体保持健康并能够繁殖、将基因传给下一代的能力）的一个主要选择压力是代谢适应性，即代谢效率。
This is a, you know, in psychology, we don't experience every hug we give, every emotion we experience, every thought we have, every insult we bear. We don't experience these things in metabolic terms. We experience them in psychological terms, but there's always a metabolic cost because there's always electrical and chemical signaling going on underneath the hood. It turns out that the metabolic cost of signaling is a major, major concern that any organism system has to deal with. When I'm in the hotel room and I hear a loud bang, my brain quickly asks itself a few questions.
这是一个，你知道，在心理学中，我们不会以代谢术语来体验我们给予的每一次拥抱、体验的每一种情绪、产生的每一个想法、忍受的每一次侮辱。我们以心理学术语来体验这些事情，但总是有代谢成本，因为在表象之下总是有电信号和化学信号在进行。事实证明，信号传递的代谢成本是任何有机体系统都必须处理的一个非常、非常重要的问题。当我在酒店房间里听到一声巨响时，我的大脑会迅速问自己几个问题。
Are these booms taking place in a war zone or a holiday resort? Second, it asks, where have I seen or heard this before? Third, and perhaps most important, it asks, what do I need to do? So the brain is basically creating prediction signals that are fundamentally, fundamentally they start not as your experience of the world, but as your actions in the world. So your every prediction signal starts as a plan for regulating the body, and then the signals come in that either confirm those predictions or change them. If there's anything that's unexpected, and in psychology, we have a fancy name for that.
这些轰鸣声是发生在战区还是度假胜地？其次，它会问，我在哪里见过或听过这个？第三，也许最重要的是，它会问，我需要做什么？所以大脑基本上是在创造预测信号，从根本上说，它们最初并不是你对世界的体验，而是你在世界中的行动。因此，你的每一个预测信号都始于一个调节身体的计划，然后传入的信号要么证实这些预测，要么改变它们。如果有什么意想不到的事情发生，在心理学中，我们有一个花哨的名字来称呼它。
We call it learning. That's what learning is. And the goal from this predictive perspective, the goal is to predict better and more efficiently the next time, right? Because at the bottom line is no matter what kind of goals we come, we sort of think about that the brain creates for itself, and that are psychological.
我们称之为学习。这就是学习的本质。从这种预测的角度来看，目标是在下一次预测得更好、更有效率，对吧？因为归根结底，无论我们产生什么样的目标，我们都会认为大脑是为自己创造这些目标的，而且它们是心理上的。
The metabolic goal is, is, is metabolic efficiency. Lisa has run many scientific experiments to spot the brain's predilection for prediction. But many years ago, she got a chance to see it in her personal life when she threw her daughter an unorthodox birthday party. When my daughter was 12, we threw her a disgust party. We had a bunch of activities that would make the children kind of exuberantly and joyfully disgusted. You know, I made pizza and I put green food coloring
代谢目标是代谢效率。丽莎进行了许多科学实验来发现大脑对预测的偏好。但多年前，当她为女儿举办了一场非传统的生日派对时，她有机会在个人生活中看到了这一点。我女儿12岁时，我们为她举办了一场“恶心派对”。我们进行了一系列活动，让孩子们感到兴高采烈、欢欣鼓舞地恶心。你知道，我做了披萨，还在帕尔马干酪上放了绿色食用色素，
on the Parmesan cheese and I made it look fuzzy like mold and I made vomit jello. So I took peach colored jello and I put little bits of vegetables in it. And I'm actually, my stomach is roiling just even talking about it. And we took white grape juice and we put it in urine cups.
让它看起来像发霉了一样，我还做了呕吐果冻。我用了桃色的果冻，在里面放了小块蔬菜。其实，光是谈论这件事，我的胃就在翻腾。我们还把白葡萄汁装进了尿杯里。
Oh my God. And the goal here was to get the kids simulating, predicting, if you will, discussed things that are very distasteful, but that they would find it really fun to do this. And they did. I mean, they were shrieking in pleasure. It was a joy to behold. First of all, it demonstrates that prediction signals are not these abstract things. They are the brain changing the firing of its own neurons to begin to construct an experience
天哪。这里的目标是让孩子们模拟、预测那些非常令人倒胃口的事情，但他们会觉得这样做非常有趣。他们确实做到了。我的意思是，他们尖叫着感到快乐。这真是一种享受。首先，这证明了预测信号不是抽象的东西。它们是大脑改变自身神经元放电以开始构建体验的过程，
before all the information is in from the environment. I mean, I have to tell you that I knew what I was doing and as I was pouring the grape juice into the urine cups, I'm telling you it smelled like pee. Like, it just, there was a whiff of pee that I could smell. And basically your brain is predicting and those predictions are real signals that construct sensory experience.
在环境信息全部传入之前。我必须告诉你，我知道我在做什么，当我把葡萄汁倒进尿杯时，我告诉你，它闻起来像尿。就像，有一股尿味我能闻到。基本上你的大脑在进行预测，而这些预测是构建感官体验的真实信号。
When we come back, how Lisa's research can help all of us take back control of our emotions. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Psychologist and neuroscientist Lisa Feldman BarBarritt is the author of the book, How Emotions Are Made, the Secret Life of the Brain. In it, she makes the case that emotions are constructed by the brain as it sits inside the cage of the skull and tries to guess the meaning of the electrical signals flooding in from the eyes and ears and skin. But if emotions are predictions that are designed to guide our behavior,
稍后回来，丽莎的研究如何帮助我们所有人重新掌控自己的情绪。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。心理学家兼神经科学家丽莎·费尔德曼·巴雷特是《情绪是如何产生的：大脑的秘密生活》一书的作者。在书中，她提出情绪是大脑在颅骨的笼子里，试图猜测从眼睛、耳朵和皮肤涌入的电信号的含义时所构建的。但如果情绪是为了引导我们行为的预测，
Lisa says we can exercise more control over those predictions than we realize. When Lisa's daughter was a toddler, she would throw tantrums. Lisa decided to help her daughter see that bad moods were really predictions and that she could choose to make different predictions. When it came to fighting a tantrum, that involved making a new prediction about a cranky fairy. I wanted to give her other options for how to experience this mood. So I invented a cranky fairy.
丽莎说，我们可以比我们意识到的更好地控制这些预测。当丽莎的女儿还是个蹒跚学步的孩子时，她会发脾气。丽莎决定帮助女儿明白坏情绪实际上是预测，她可以选择做出不同的预测。当涉及到对抗发脾气时，这涉及到一个关于“暴躁仙女”的新预测。我想给她提供其他体验这种情绪的选择。所以我发明了一个暴躁仙女。
When she would start to feel cranky or crabby, it meant that the cranky fairy was coming to visit. And then whenever she would feel the cranky fairy preparing to make a visit, we gave her a special chair, an Elmo chair, a chair that was like a little, a little Elmo character from Sesame Street, and that she could go to and sit in the chair when the cranky fairy was visiting and sort of vanquish the cranky fairy from her life for that day.
当她开始感到暴躁或易怒时，这意味着暴躁仙女要来拜访了。然后，每当她感觉到暴躁仙女准备来访时，我们就给她一把特殊的椅子，一把艾摩椅子，一把像《芝麻街》里艾摩角色的椅子，当暴躁仙女来访时，她可以去坐在那把椅子上，把暴躁仙女从她那一天的生活中赶走。
And over time, what happened was she would actually march herself to the chair when she felt like she was going to lose control and have a dantrum and she would sit in that chair and you know she might look at a book or she might play with some plastic animals or she might but basically she was teaching herself how to regulate her own behavior and so these stories wove together to you you know, give her options, other options than just making emotions, negative emotions out of the sensations that she was experiencing. But there's a larger lesson in this for all of us, not just for two-year-olds, which is
随着时间的推移，发生的事情是，当她觉得自己要失去控制并大发脾气时，她会自己走到椅子前，坐在那把椅子上，你知道，她可能会看书，或者玩塑料动物，但基本上她是在教自己如何调节自己的行为。所以这些故事交织在一起，给你，你知道，给她除了仅仅从她正在经历的感觉中制造负面情绪之外的其他选择。但这对我们所有人来说都有一个更大的教训，不仅仅是针对两岁小孩，那就是
that when we experience emotions, those emotions in some ways as you're pointing out are predictions about what the world is like, what we should be feeling, how we should be responding, but those are predictions. And in exactly the same way that you taught your daughter to in some ways create a different social reality, we have some control over our emotions in ways that many of us might not realize. Exactly. And, you know, none of us have as much control as we would like. Engaining control is a little harder than anyone might want. But if a three-year-old can do it, And, you know, none of us have as much control as we would like. Engaining control is a little harder than anyone might want.
当我们体验情绪时，这些情绪在某种程度上正如你所指出的，是对世界是什么样、我们应该有什么感觉、我们应该如何反应的预测，但这些都是预测。正如你教导女儿在某种程度上创造不同的社会现实一样，我们对自己的情绪也有一些控制力，这是许多人可能没有意识到的。没错。而且，你知道，我们谁也没有我们想要的那么多控制权。获得控制权比任何人想要的都要难一点。但如果一个三岁的小孩能做到，而且，你知道，我们谁也没有我们想要的那么多控制权。获得控制权比任何人想要的都要难一点。
But if a three-year-old can do it, then anybody can do it. And the point here is that we created a context for her to rewire her brain in a sense. Right? She could take advantage of the situation to give herself new experiences that the brain would learn so that her brain would predict later in a different way. So at first, she would sit in the chair after she had a tantrum and then she would sit in the chair right before she was having a tantrum and then she might go sit in the chair, even when the situation might in 10 or 15 minutes prompt a tantrum, she was able to practice this skill, and it was hard at first, but it's just like driving,
但如果一个三岁的小孩能做到，那么任何人都能做到。这里的重点是我们为她创造了一个环境，让她在某种意义上重塑她的大脑。对吧？她可以利用这种情况给自己新的体验，让大脑学习，这样她的大脑以后就会以不同的方式进行预测。所以起初，她在发脾气后会坐在椅子上，然后她在发脾气前会坐在椅子上，然后她甚至在15或20分钟后可能会引发脾气的情况下也会去坐椅子，她能够练习这种技能，起初很难，但这就像开车一样，
basically. It's hard at first. It takes a lot of energy. It's an investment in being a better you in the future. Mm-hmm. There's another important insight that you are raising here, Lisa, which is that when we experience emotions, if we start to see them as predictions about the world, one thing we might do is, instead of simply following our emotions, we might actually be curious
基本上。起初很难。它需要大量的能量。这是对未来成为更好的自己的一种投资。嗯。丽莎，你在这里提出了另一个重要的见解，那就是当我们体验情绪时，如果我们开始把它们看作是对世界的预测，我们可能会做的一件事是，与其简单地跟随我们的情绪，我们实际上可能会对它们感到好奇。
about them. We say, what is causing me to feel this way? What are the factors that might be driving this? So in other words, you're sitting across someone at a coffee shop and your face feels flushed. Instead of automatically saying, I'm attracted to this person, you could say, what might be the different reasons my face is flushed?
我们问，是什么导致我有这种感觉？可能驱动这些因素的原因是什么？所以换句话说，你坐在咖啡店里对面坐着某人，你的脸感到发烫。与其自动说，我被这个人吸引了，你不如说，我脸发烫的不同原因可能是什么？
Exactly. And curiosity is really, I think, underrated and undervalued in our culture, particularly at this particular moment in time. So this is something that works when you are really, even in the throes of great difficulty, you can become curious instead of becoming confident that you know what the causes of a set of sensations. So a perfect example of this was when my daughter was 12, she was testing for her black belt in karate. She was barely
没错。而且我认为好奇心在我们的文化中被低估和贬值了，特别是在这个特定的时刻。所以当你真的处于极度困难之中时，这是一种有效的方法，你可以变得好奇，而不是确信你知道一组感觉的原因。所以一个完美的例子是，当我女儿12岁时，她正在参加空手道黑带考试。她几乎
five feet tall and she was going to have to spar that is fight with these like six foot hulking adolescent boys in order to get her black belt. In her sensei, who was this 10th degree black belt, this guy could break a board by looking at it, sort of saunters up to her and he crosses his arms and he says, get your butterflies flying in formation. And I thought, that is brilliant because he's not saying become because she needs that arousal in order to perform in order to do the test. But he gave her a different meaning for it
五英尺高，她将不得不与这些六英尺高、魁梧的青春期男孩进行对打，也就是搏斗，才能获得黑带。她的老师，那位十段黑带，这个家伙看一眼就能劈开木板，他漫步走到她身边，交叉双臂说，让你的蝴蝶排成队飞行。我想，这太聪明了，因为他不是说变得，因为她需要那种唤醒来表现，为了参加考试。但他给了她一个不同的含义，
and therefore she had a different set of actions that were available to her. You make the point in the book that one of the things the brain does is that it is very carefully calibrating how much energy it's using and making predictions about how much energy it needs. And many of our mood states, in fact, are the brain's predictions about what is coming and how much it has by way of stored energy. What are the implications here for ordinary people, Lisa, with this idea, especially when it comes to things like food and exercise and sleep, you know, when we think about our well-being, what does your science say about those things that everyone struggles with?
因此她有了一套不同的行动方案。你在书中指出，大脑所做的事情之一是它非常仔细地校准它正在使用的能量，并对它需要多少能量做出预测。事实上，我们的许多情绪状态是大脑对即将发生的事情以及它拥有多少储存能量的预测。丽莎，这个想法对普通人有什么影响，特别是在食物、锻炼和睡眠方面，你知道，当我们考虑我们的健康时，你的科学对每个人都在挣扎的这些事情有什么说法？
Evolution tells us very clearly that the brain's most important job is coordinating and regulating the body in the most metabolically efficient way. And you put it beautifully that the brain is always attempting to predict what its energy needs will be in the next moment. Because that's the most efficient way to run a body. Brains regulate the body, the energetic needs of the body by anticipating those needs and attempting to meet those needs before they arise. The metaphor that I often use for the brain's regulation
进化非常清楚地告诉我们，大脑最重要的工作是以最代谢有效的方式协调和调节身体。你表达得很美，大脑总是试图预测它在下一刻的能量需求。因为这是运行身体最有效的方式。大脑通过预期这些需求并试图在需求出现之前满足它们来调节身体，调节身体的能量需求。我经常用来形容大脑调节
of the body is that the brain is running a budget for the body. So the technical term for the predictive regulation of the body is allostasis. But the metaphor is body budgeting. Your brain is running a budget for your body. It's not budgeting money, it's budgeting glucose and salt and oxygen and so on. Depression is like a bankrupt body budget. It's basically your brain is attempting to reduce its costs. And in doing this, it will create fatigue, which will lead you to move less.
身体的隐喻是，大脑正在为身体运行预算。所以预测性身体调节的专业术语是“异稳态”。但这个隐喻是“身体预算”。你的大脑正在为你的身体运行预算。它不是在预算金钱，而是在预算葡萄糖、盐、氧气等等。抑郁症就像一个破产的身体预算。基本上你的大脑正在试图减少开支。在这样做时，它会产生疲劳，这将导致你减少活动。
So that's a reduction in cost. The brain is like trapped in its predictions. It's not going to update. It's not going to learn from prediction error because learning is metabolically expensive. So even if there are pleasant things, like things in the world that could lead you to experience pleasure, you won't pay attention to them
所以那是成本的降低。大脑就像被困在它的预测中。它不会更新。它不会从预测错误中学习，因为学习在代谢上是昂贵的。所以即使有令人愉快的事情，比如世界上可能导致你体验快乐的事情，你也不会关注它们，
and you won't learn about them, you won't take advantage of them because it's just too expensive. So basically the brain is trapped in these predictions that will lead to more unpleasant or continuing unpleasant mood. So when you feel stressed, it's because your brain has predicted that a big metabolic outlay is going to be necessary in the next moment. So like when you're being criticized by someone or when someone is bullying you or when you're having conflicts with people and so on. And then if you add to that
你也不会了解它们，你也不会利用它们，因为这太昂贵了。所以基本上大脑被困在这些预测中，这将导致更多不愉快或持续的不愉快情绪。所以当你感到压力时，是因为你的大脑预测到下一刻将需要大量的代谢支出。比如当你被某人批评时，或者当有人欺负你时，或者当你与人发生冲突时等等。然后如果你加上
maybe not getting enough sleep or maybe not eating healthfully or not exercising on a regular basis. or not exercising on a regular basis. What happens is that your brain becomes less and less and less able to efficiently regulate the body. And that, you will experience that as negative mood. You will experience that as fatigue or distress. And typically, we have psychological explanations. When you feel bad, you look to the world to figure out what's wrong with the world.
也许睡眠不足，或者饮食不健康，或者没有定期锻炼。会发生什么呢？你的大脑调节身体的能力变得越来越弱。你会将其体验为负面情绪。你会将其体验为疲劳或痛苦。通常，我们有心理学解释。当你感觉不好时，你会向世界寻找原因，找出世界出了什么问题。
And if you can't figure out what's wrong with the world, you assume there's something wrong with you. But actually, it could just be that there is a metabolic answer to your negative mood. Do you feel like you have used these ideas, I mean, the ideas that you have about the brain is a prediction machine, do you feel like you use these ideas yourself Lisa in your life? Do you feel like you stop yourself sometimes
如果你找不出世界出了什么问题，你会认为是你自己出了问题。但实际上，可能只是你的负面情绪有一个代谢答案。你觉得你使用过这些想法吗？我是说，你关于大脑是预测机器的想法，丽莎，你觉得你在生活中使用过这些想法吗？你觉得你有时会阻止自己吗？
when you've jumped to a conclusion about something and sort of say, is this really how the world is or is it just a prediction I'm making? Every day, all the time. I didn't come to these scientific insights for the purpose of using them in my own life, but I absolutely do. And here are two that I find really useful. One is from my husband, actually, which is other people's opinions of you are merely electrical activity in their brains.
当你对某事得出结论时，你会说，这真的是世界的样子，还是仅仅是我做出的预测？每天，一直都在用。我得出这些科学见解并不是为了在自己的生活中使用它们，但我绝对会用。这里有两个我觉得非常有用的。一个是来自我丈夫，实际上，就是别人对你的看法仅仅是他们大脑中的电活动。
I love that. Yeah, it's really useful in faculty meetings. Hahaha. The other one is, this is from Buddhist philosophy, which is anger is a form of ignorance. It prompts you to be curious about why someone is doing something that you might not like and that you might find even offensive, but they have a reason for doing it.
我喜欢这个。是的，在教职员会议上非常有用。哈哈。另一个是，这来自佛教哲学，即愤怒是一种无知。它促使你对为什么某人做了一些你可能不喜欢甚至可能觉得冒犯的事情感到好奇，但他们有这样做的理由。
And if you try to take their perspective for a minute, you still might not like it, but you won't be angry anymore. It just turns down the dial on the intensity of your discomfort in a way that I find to be really productive. Lisa Feldman Barrett is a psychologist at Northeastern University. She's the author of How Emotions Are Made, The Secret Life of the Brain, and seven and a half lessons about the brain. Lisa, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. It's Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz,
如果你试着站在他们的角度想一分钟，你可能仍然不喜欢它，但你不会再愤怒了。它以一种我觉得非常有效的方式调低了你不安的强度。丽莎·费尔德曼·巴雷特是东北大学的心理学家。她是《情绪是如何产生的：大脑的秘密生活》和《关于大脑的七个半课程》的作者。丽莎，非常感谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。这是隐藏大脑媒体。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲·保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、
Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbrain. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you enjoy the show and want more of our work, please join Hidden Brain Plus, our podcast subscription on Apple Podcasts. Hidden Brain Plus is a great way to support the show and get access to exclusive conversations you won't hear anywhere else. You can find it by searching for Hidden Brain on the Apple Podcasts app or by going to apple.co slash Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vidantam. See you soon. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德布雷恩。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。如果你喜欢这个节目并想要我们更多的作品，请加入《隐藏的大脑》Plus，我们在Apple Podcasts上的播客订阅。《隐藏的大脑》Plus是支持该节目并获得你在其他任何地方都听不到的独家对话的好方法。你可以通过在Apple Podcasts应用程序中搜索“Hidden Brain”或访问apple.co/HiddenBrain来找到它。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。谢谢。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。